[Music]
when you took the two Rapid Shots and
imagine it I'm talking about it was pop
hop right like boom boom and what are
you shooting with I shot a hk416 that's
the gun that took out the yeah and I was
shooting us a 5.56 millimeter and you
described that his head kind of exploded
yes when you I actually hit him three
times so I shot him twice when he was
standing and once on the ground just
because it it doesn't take long for a
suicide bomber to clack his vest off so
I need to make sure he's not mobile it
always are the best kill of your life I
mean like why was there such
satisfaction or was there a feeling of
emptiness
well it didn't hit at first that's the
[ __ ] who blew up the world trade mean
he was the one who didn't hit at first
because we still had a woman in there
and his like three-year-old kid was
there right and we had to kind of clear
the room I remember looking at the kid
thinking this poor guy's got nothing to
do with this fight that just happened
right and once we put his mom on the bed
and him on the bed it started to sink in
and one of my buddies came up to me and
he kind of looked at me and he goes hey
are you good and I said I said yeah what
do we do now and he smiled he said well
now we go find the computers we've done
this hundreds of times and I know a
different mission right and I said I
said you're right I'm back holy [ __ ] you
go Cheryl you just kill bin Laden like
your life just changed let's take a
silent pause for a second thank God you
were successful in your mission and
let's reflect on this we got bin Laden
you are out of the all the people in the
military you put the bullet in three
times it's just the tactics got me there
god bless you thank you for saying that
Phyllis that's it it was it was the
analyst that sounded may God bless you
for all those people who lost someone at
9/11 that's why we went we we we went in
that mission expansionism expecting to
die right and we accepted it and
actually that I think the point meant
and I were talking but he was the point
meant yet but we were talking about it
we were discussing why we're going and
we said we're not going for Fame and
we're not going for bravado we're going
for the single mom who dropped her kids
off at school on a Tuesday morning and
45 minutes later she jumped to her death
out of a skyscraper yeah because that
was a better alternative than burning
alive and her last gesture of human
decency was holding her skirt down so no
because here under us killed herself
yeah we're going to hurt it to me that's
the worst but like thinking of those
people's last decision that's and that's
the better choice
you